[Music]
sometimes a new exciting opportunity
presents itself when we are completely
happy about our existing life situation
if that happens we are forced to think
about opportunity costs
this is because when we look at the new
opportunity we compare it with our
current situation and think about what
is at stake if we would go for it this
often happens without us being able to
see the full picture
economists define opportunity cost as
the benefit we forego as we trade off
one alternative for another hoping we
make the best choice
although they are often less obvious and
sometimes speculative opportunity costs
can be huge
therefore learning about them makes
sense
imagine that we are trying to calculate
the true cost of going to college
one factor can be tuition which in our
case is ten thousand dollars since
that's our only cost
you might conclude that the cost of
college is ten thousand dollars a year
but to economists that's not quite right
because we have to add the money we
could have earned by working instead of
attending college
say that by working full-time in a local
restaurant you can earn twenty thousand
dollars a year
the true costs of going to college are
therefore ten thousand dollars tuition
plus twenty thousand dollars in
opportunity costs by studying for a
degree we trade off 30 000 a year
although that's only half the story
because it also goes the other way
around
assuming we go to college for four years
we trade off a hundred and twenty
thousand dollars for an education that
leaves us with empty pockets many ideas
and a degree
however once we are better educated we
might be able to make forty thousand
dollars as a manager instead of the
twenty thousand dollars in service in
such a case not going to college ends up
being much more expensive
do you understand the concept show us
calculate the opportunity costs of a
high school student who drops the idea
of earning a degree in medicine and
instead chooses to help in the family
business
the cost for tuition and living is two
thousand dollars a month it takes a
total of six years to finish university
after obtaining her degree she works in
the field of medicine for 34 years
earning 10 000 a month and spending 3
000 on monthly living expenses if she is
entering the family business she earns 3
500 right away for the next 40 years
with zero living expenses
what's financially the better choice
post your calculations in the comments
below
[Music]
this and all other sprouts videos are
licensed under creative commons that
means teachers from all around the world
can use them in classrooms online
courses or to start projects and today
thousands already do
to learn how it works and download this
video without ads or background music
check out our website or read the
description below
if you want to support our mission and
help change education visit our patreon
that's patreon.com
sprouts